Ukraine's counter-offensive
is only just getting started.
But the early assessment by U.S.
officials who spoke to CNN is that so far
expectations are not being met
on any front
It seems Russian
defenses are more resilient
than expected,
and Russian mines
and airstrikes have bogged down
Ukrainian forces in some parts.
Still, the long term outlook
remains optimistic.
Ukrainian officials on Thursday
pushed back, saying
defensive lines in the east are holding
and gains are being made,
albeit slowly in the south.
Here's more from Ukraine's prime minister
Counter-offensive is not.
Hollywood movie is not easy walk.
Counter-offensive
is number of military operations.
Sometimes it's offensive.
Sometimes it's defensive.
Sometimes it could be tactical pauses.
Unfortunate it dudek our preparation
for this counteroffensive.
Russians were preparing to.
So there is so much
minefields which
really make it slower to
I mean movement into their head.
Ukrainian forces have inflicted
what appears to be a serious blow
in the south
A missile strike
leaving a key bridge
to Russian occupied Crimea badly damaged.
The Chon Ha bridge is now
closed to traffic,
and Kremlin
backed officials
say it will take weeks to repair
one of the few crossings
that connect Crimea
with the occupied occupied part
of southern Ukraine.
And according to a former Ukrainian
defense minister,
shutting this bridge down now
creates a major chokepoint for Russian
supply lines.
Details now from CNN's Matthew Chance.
For now,
let's live in a hacktivist of us.
So now as
the battles on Russian state television.
News of the latest Ukrainian strike
administrative on the ground
punching through a key bridge to Crimea.
For Slava,
the military supply
routes, the anchor says,
which Ukraine hit with missiles
to cut off.
Instead of hiding the bad news.
Russia is using it to bolster support for
the Kremlin appointed
governor of occupied.
Her son
was quickly at the scene
to condemn the attack and blame the West.
This is in
that it's
another senseless act by the Kiev regime
at the behest of London, he says.
But it will make no difference
to the results
of the special military operation
what Russia calls its war
along the vast front lines in Ukraine.
A much anticipated counter offensive
is seeing fierce but limited fighting
Some Ukrainian officials are pushing back
hard, though, on Western assessments
to CNN
that expectations are not being met.
Really?
One senior Ukrainian
official telling CNN
it's still way too early
to assess the overall trajectory
of what the official says
was shaping operations.
The real counteroffensive,
the official told CNN,
has not even begun yet in earnest.
Still, the Russian military is
taking credit
for holding Ukrainian forces
back to a level it was
releasing dramatic images
of what they say are enemy positions
being pounded.
Characterizing
the Ukrainian push as unsuccessful.
The Kremlin though, is sounding
an unusual note of caution.
Moscow established to Mr.
Putin.
Ukraine's offensive potential has not yet
been exhausted.
The Russian president warns
his defense officials
its strategic reserves, he says,
have not all been activated.
But it is a recognition of what
Ukrainian officials also insist.
This battle may be slow
but it is far from over.
Matthew Chance, CNN, Kiev.